okay so last night marvel maniacs
noticed there'd been a strange
new update to the post-credits scene of
the one division finale
episode nine ended with wonder maxum off
out at what may or may not be
wondergoal mountain in the original
scene we watched as she sat sipping some
tea
after successfully ruining the lives of
an entire town
and getting away with it scot-free now
wonder had gained the darkhold
and as she walked around outside of the
cabin we saw that inside her astral
projection
was reading through the book the theme
of doctor strange then started c bin
and we heard the voices of her children
calling out to her
now there is a slight update to the
scene and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the
differences
and possibilities of what could be going
on it might be nothing like my entire
existence
but there has been a clear change that i
think does kind of highlight some little
key things
as always if you miss one division then
smash the thumbs up button
as what is a thumbs up if not a thumbs
down persevering
also subscribe as we'd love to have you
around here and we do breakdowns on
marvel shows and movies every single
week
anyway without the way thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
the breakdown
okay so firstly i think we have to look
at the original post-credits scene
so we can first establish what's being
changed this video
is gonna be a bit like playing spot the
difference on a pub quiz machine
but there are some minor minor changes
now the first shot has us flying in
and we continue on this path until we
reach the cabin this is definitely how
the original looks
as i turned i mean i had i had a friend
who works at disney that gave me a copy
of the episode
so i could edit my finale breakdown for
it now looking at this nothing really
going on here out of the ordinary
however jump forward to what's playing
this month and when we zoom in you might
notice that there are some extra trees
around the area
on screen right now i've put the images
on top of one another and you want to be
looking on the left hand side especially
as you can see that there are completely
different shrubs there
is shrubber weird i don't know but are
you still looking
okay okay can we move on now okay so
clearly the area has been changed
digitally
and someone has just gone wild with the
clone tool now why this has likely been
done
is because this is going to link in with
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
from what i know of behind the scenes
stuff on the production wonder is the
main villain in it
and the reason that they've changed this
is to likely line things up a lot more
with that movie
if youtube has taught us anything it's
that people love correction tiny
mistakes
and no doubt if the scenery looked
different people would have pointed it
out
also i said correction there instead of
correcting just to see if you would
point it out and you either fell for it
or you didn't
but either way you're a sucker now the
tie-in with doctor strange has been
hammered home by a strange floating
figure that can be seen in the scene
as well as in addition to the credits on
screen now is how the original credits
appeared back in march
however if we do a little fade in to how
they look now
we can see that the composer of
strange's theme has been added
as well as the credits for it jump into
the third new detail in the scene
and take a look at the trees and you
might notice that a strange
blurred figure is descending towards the
cabin let's view that zoomed in
and you can see it a lot clearer here it
looks like a pointed figure
perhaps wearing a cape or a cloak and
it's just very very eerie it's a it's a
lot like
bigfoot they're all bigfoot footage
where it might be nothing
but it could be the most significant
thing that's ever happened in the mcu
and i will do this one more time with a
lot more attention drawn to it
and it definitely stands out against the
backdrop though it looks like the
predator is swooping in to kill wander
there are a number of things that it
could be now firstly if this
is tied into doctor strange then this
could definitely be the astral
projection of the character
swooping in to see what's going on with
one day if you've ever read the graphic
novel house of m
then you know he was a paramount
character in it when it came to fighting
her
in the book wanda had created a false
reality and after the heroes snapped out
of it
they went to confront her face to face
the figure seems to be moving in this
direction
and several months after the release of
one division we learn from kevin feige
that doctor strange was originally meant
to be in the show
fagi said that the commercials we saw
were actually strange reaching into the
hex in order to try and snap wonder out
of it
and this is why they pulled from certain
things in her life it's a shame that
these scenes were scrapped as it would
have tied in a lot more with the
upcoming movie
but who knows marvel might be cheeky and
patchy update their post-credits scenes
even more
like some lazy game developer now
another possibility is that
this is the devil himself
however on top of this if it is indeed
set at wondergoal mountain
then it could be cathon the chaos god
that actually created the darkhold
interestingly he ended up possessing the
body of quicksilver in the comics and
for a long time
well like two weeks or something there
were a lot of people that thought ralph
bona may be him
her boner now the third possibility is
that it's vision
the season finale had a big moment in it
in which the hex version of vision ended
up passing on his memories and
personality to the repurposed death bot
that hayward had built in order to
provide a line of security for the
planet
one division was full of hexes and in
the show vision actually broke out of an
octagonal window
at the end octagons also tend to hold a
lot of meaning
and whilst a hexagon means to hold
something or trap it
an octagon means to free it now we have
no idea what happened to vision
or where he went off to but it's likely
that he wanted to learn about what
happened to him
and this would likely send him across
the planet in search of what's been
going on in the five years since his
death
the last thing he knew was that wonder
killed him in order to destroy the mind
stone
and the character would still be in love
with her so finding out that she was
here
would probably send him out there to
rekindle their romance so that she could
get it on with a toaster once more
instead of spending
all day boning that kettle well
something's gotta be making the tea
and i don't see any electrical pulls out
there yet do you
do you see any electrical poles well
maybe you should be doing the breakdown
zen now
lastly this could be absolutely nothing
and it may just be
a cgi artifact that has been left in the
final edit
when you're entering stuff sometimes
bugs and glitches happen that mean
weird effects get laid over videos and i
have to say that this thing doesn't
change your altar in size the closer
that we get
which is what would happen if it was
truly in the landscape
therefore it may just be a glitch but it
does seem weird that they would look
over a clip containing this
and still decide to upload it in place
of a scene that was absolutely fine in
the first place
now stepping back and looking at
everything this has clearly been put in
place to tie in more with doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness
which is likely going to be the next
film that features wonder
it's interesting that they've done this
and no doubt fans will now be on the
lookout for the most minor of changes in
post-credits scenes
maybe we'll even get an updated falcon
in the winter soldier one
that explains who's on the other end of
the phone or maybe this entire video was
just a reach
trying to cash in on the latest talking
point in the mcu
i'll let you be the judge of that one
you sucker but in the meantime i'd love
to hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the clip the
winners of last month's competition are
on screen right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of doctor strange
in which we notice some brand new
details that tie into not only loki but
also one division
it's linked on screen right now and the
deals are really really cool
so definitely go check it out after this
without the way thank you for singing
through the video
i've been poor and i'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you